juste te poser une question simple
alors j'ai déjà pris un rond-point en
sens inverse vers moi je sais compter
jusqu'à 100 dans plus de 40 langues
différentes moi j'ai déjà piloter un
avion
tu as déjà piloté renard je flippe de
tout ce que je fais maintenant avec le
clignement des yeux away
[Musique]
salut bienvenue pour cette analyse
numéro c'est pas il y en a beaucoup trop
de l'analyse sur cette chaîne
aujourd'hui est un jour intéressant
parce que je fais à baliser 12 mensonge
que j'ai déjà analysé en direct à la
radio mais je me dis comme on a pu
récupérer la vidéo est d'ailleurs merci
à énergie nous avoir donné la vidéo
radio stream va inviter donc sur nrj le
soir à partir de 21h je crois c'est
l'émission de braquer louis et sans
prévenir à l'avancé qu'ils avaient
préparées 12 mensonges qu'ils allaient
me balancer et c'était à moi d'être bon
et en plus c'est drôle parce que j'ai
toujours la pression même genre une fois
avec domingo on avait fait ça aussi et
j'ai pas été bons partout donc la petit
spoil
mais j'ai pas été mauvais sur ce coup là
et c'est ça qui va être aussi
intéressant pour regarder en fait
pourquoi j'ai pu déceler à chaque fois
comme augmenter ou quand tu disais la
vérité
bref c'est parti loïc génériques même si
en fait il ya déjà eu un générique du
coup pas de générique à toi de dire si
chacun avec son toit est vrai ou faux ok
je proposais des petites questions
on va se limiter à une question
ouais mais là il me met déjà le stress
mais moi je dis juste ce truc là toute
basique de ce que je peux poser des
questions après parce que si on me dit
juste mon chat s'appelle arthur bas j'ai
pas assez d'éléments en fait émotionnel
le mensonge ça se détecte dans l'est les
incohérences dans les variations
émotionnelle dans plein de choses comme
ça donc faudra pas se gourer sur la
question que je pose alors j'ai déjà
conduit un tramway vrai ou faux
ok il a essayé de me brainfuck parce
qu'il faisait oui avec sa tête en même
temps mais comme et regarder les vidéos
tu vas donc je me dis qu'il a essayé de
manipuler
il marque un parc à lui seul 3 une
question juste là qu'est ce que tu
analyses là qu'il a fait oui de la tête
quant à 10 ha ouais mais que c'est un
oui forcé donc c'était pendant dur en
erreur et qui me regardait fixement dans
les yeux d'un match
je vais juste te poser une question
c'est sur combien de stations sur une
dizaine à peu près tout le monde chez
eux qui font pas vraiment timo oui alors
là là c'était clairement lui poser la
bonne question pour lui mettre la
pression et en lui demandant son nombre
d' arrêt tram le fait qu'ils répondent
très vite sur une dizaine d'arrêts de
tram c il a il a même pas eu à besoin de
retourner dans ses souvenirs donc on a
déjà comme deux éléments deux indices de
mensonge donc là le troisième il était
clair il était cache ce que tu as déjà
fait voilà on essaie de savoir c'est
vrai ou faux alors j'ai déjà pris un
rond-point en sens inverse
regardez ce petit visage gêné et le
mouvement qu'elle a fait sur sa chaise
et le menton qui est penché vers le bac
un signe de honte
tout ça ce sont des indices parce qu'on
n'est jamais sûr et certain que
quelqu'un dise la vérité aux montants ça
n'existe pas d'être sûre et certaine ça
mais c'est déjà beaucoup de faisceaux
pour dire que c'est vrai selon moi c'est
vrai parce que à la une crispation de la
mâchoire mais tu n'en donne un nom qui
montrent en fait le même genre de
crispation que tu as quand tu es jeune
et que tu as honte
donc je là je l'interprète en mode j'ai
déjà contre lui
à l'envers sur un rond-point et [ __ ]
merde des autres quoi toi et bien moi je
sais compter jusqu'à 100 dans plus de 40
langues différentes
dans plus de quinze langues différentes
comme toi qui es tu veux dire non mais
qu'ils ont sur les quinze langues
ah ben je peux te donner français
espagnol anglais polonais hongrois russe
turc est allé dire anglais des états
unis parce que je le fais avec un accent
car c'était trop si on trouve la bonne
question
la question qui n'est pas dans le
jugement c'est juste ah oui c'est quoi
les quinze s'il te plaît parce que ce
chiffre est tellement énorme que c'est
une galère et à la limite si ça avait
été vrai orgue et attend 15 il faut que
je réfléchisse parce que je les ai déjà
compté mais je ne connais pas par coeur
comme ça de tête là le rien que le fait
qu'il fasse ah oui pas de problème
français nana na na na na tu sais qu'il
va pas pouvoir garder le débit il est
parti trop vite c'est complètement
anormale où il allait dire jeune
espagnol et péruviens qui parle mais ma
confiance au début
alors moi j'ai rencontré jean pierre
foucault dans un cirque là c'était très
dur
vous avez pu voir à quel point elle
était très neutre dans son intonation
dans sa gestuelle dans son visage
donc là la question elle va être
déterminante très jean pierre foucault
dans c'est incroyable cette histoire et
on a eu quand je dis c'est la preuve que
cette histoire je gagne du temps pour
réfléchir à ma question clairement on le
coup un petit hochement de la tête qui
veut dire oui le même que bracke a voulu
me stimule et je te penses - ps -
perverse que brac je dirais que c'est
vrai du coup
ok très bien moi j'en ai une également
mais moi aussi j'en ai deux et je te
fais pas une émission radio pour le dire
monsieur
alors oui petit aparté un clairement les
émissions de radio le soir le 21 heures
minuit je suis plus relâché on va se
prendre un petit club du ca demain moi
j'ai déjà piloter un avion
tu as déjà piloté renâcle aux flics de
tout ce que je fais maintenant avec le
clignement des yeux
là on a quand même eu la validation
si loïc tu peux leur maître on voit déjà
à quel point il ay là il a commencé à
valider et de la manière dont il s'est
assis est ce que tu peux me raconter
juste c'est ça ma question est la
sensation que tu as eu au moment où tu
sens la portance arrivés en deux manches
tu sors l'importance arrivé sous les
ailes c'est très impressionnant je ne
pensais pas que ça se prend la voie là
bas c'est vrai là je voulais savoir ce
qu'il allait dire mais la manière dont
elles il dirait en fait il l'a dit
vraiment comme ça avec un hochement de
tête un seul mais très franc est
vraiment en mode on sait de quoi on
parle tous les deux est ce juste j'ai le
plaisir il ya des années de le faire des
cours d'apprentissage de pilotage et du
coup je sais que je pourrai voir s'il a
vécu ce truc que je vécu aussi alors
l'émission allait en direct sur nrj
évidemment mais en même temps elle est
diffusée sur sur twitch donc c'est aussi
pour ça qu'on a pu récupérer le
le flux vidéo donc je voulais vraiment
remercier louis et braque que vous
pouvez aussi retrouver sur install sur
les réseaux et tous et leurs producteurs
de m'avoir fourni l'image dans la
deuxième session j'ai une idée je vais
couper juste avant à chaque fois la
réponse dès que la personne a dit
mensonge pour que vous puissiez le dire
en commentaire si vous pensez que la
personne ment ou ou si elle dit la
réponse suite et fin de ce jeu du qui
ment les amis fabien les connaissez
de quoi il restait des manceaux il reste
un petit peu le manceau aurait pu partir
sur un 100 foot merde donc en remettent
leur titre en jeu dès 10h le prochain a
pas cessé
on le voit mon visage là que je suis
crispé et stressés et c'est vrai en plus
c'est à dire que moi la pause je pense
que ça se termine et qu'on va faire
autre chose et je me dis ok ça va c'est
cool j'ai géré sur les 5
j'ai eu 5 bonnes réponses quoi il le
fait qu'il remette le titre en jeu ça
m'arrange pas du tout braquo brac où
j'étais clown alors laissez moi parler
parce que tu vas déjà rentré dans mon
cerveau dont dieu j'ai charlie spice boy
avec sabrina ok alors est-ce que bracke
a déjà chanté boys boys boys avec
sabrina
je vous laisse me dire dans les
commentaires mais surtout étayer votre
réponse vous me dire pourquoi ce serait
vrai ou pourquoi ce serait faux
c'est ça qui m'intéresse reste quelques
secondes et on peut remettre la réponse
et je la compléterait je pense tu as
chanté boys boys boys avec sabrina
oui un écart d'âge pourtant way petit
écart quand même ok et donc c'était dans
quel à quel moment de ta vie c'était
pendant un tournage excuse moi excusez
nous on a dépassé on a juste dépassé en
fait la question
ouais c'est la deuxième question donc
c'est moi même mais sûrement talibans
mais on veut médias la réponse est oui
c'était vrai à 99%
vous avez vu le équipe remettre ça le
moment où il dit cette affirmation il a
il a juste ce mouvement là au niveau du
front saturn une fraction de seconde
c'est très rapide mais c'est parce que
c'est sa petite fierté et donc c'est un
peu tu as vu ce que j'ai fait ou pas et
ça c'est incontrôlée et incontrôlable et
c'est en vrai grâce à ça que je savais
que c'était la vérité après les autres
détails par donc quand je lui posais la
question lane regarder plus dans les
yeux pour réfléchir
il cherchait un petit peu à côté dans sa
tête pour revenir vers moi quand j avais
posé la question sur le nombre de
stations
de tramway là il m'a regardé vérité en
disant une dizaine directement vous avez
vu la différence entre aller chercher
dans ses souvenirs ou pas là c'est
flagrant est d'ailleurs plus on fait ce
jeu là cet exercice là sur la même
personne
et plus on arrive à sentir ces
variations personnel mais soulever des
chaussures nation a demandé aux
militants je te vois mal et avant je te
vois je n'entends que le son de ma voix
je suis la descendante d'une famille
royale suédoise
je vais laisser tourner pour que vous
ayez la question que je vous pose parce
que vous avez pas vu son visage suédoise
en plus et quand comment vous l'avez
découvert en fait je le sais puisque
c'est un grand mère qui le savent et qui
nous l'a dit en fait à partir de là est
ce que vous pensez qu'elle dit la vérité
ou pas et pareil souvenez vous c'est
comme bike avec braque ou juste avant
souvenez-vous des comportements qu'elle
avait tout à l'heure essayez aussi de
voir s'il ya une variation ou pas c'est
bon elle a répondu dans l'est comme m'a
dit moi aussi si vous mettez pas dans
les comm forcément quand c'est beaucoup
de en fait ya beaucoup trop de mots
parasites pour moi c'est un mytho
meilleur matin la prod alors moi je sais
dire sans chiffres dont j'ai déjà gravi
les malaya à dallas il faut il faut
remettre le passage le 14e l'essai de
leur maître mois qu'on le voit au moment
où il fait son affirmation et là vous
pourrez venir
j'ai déjà gravi les malaya statut à la
bafouille et lin mais je m'en fous du
bafouillages parce que moi j'ai vu que
l'excitation avec les qui s'ouvre la
dilatation limites de la pupille en mode
c'est un bon gars ça c'est pas de la
merde je pense que c'est vrai allez y
avait cette fierté à l'été des rings qui
s'est redressée il a été comme ça
c'était fou et moi j'ai déjà rencontré
donald trump
là vous n'avez pas eu le visage encore
dommage mais vous allez voir quand j'ai
posé la question et pas trouvé si elles
m'ont aussi elle dit la vérité peut être
déjà quand des gens car c'est surtout à
un aéroport ya deux ans alors d'après
vous ça c'est vrai ou pas j'ai dit elle
c'était la plus dure à lire
un mois je trouve qu'elle est illisible
sahara alors or ambré là ce qui se passe
j'aurais eu tendance à dire que c'était
vrai mais je veux dire tu me bien que
après que c'est un mytho parce que je
pense qu'elle aurait rajouté à détails
de style at-elle aéroports dans ce cas
alors on va voir la réponse de quelques
secondes mais en gros ça fait partie des
signaux de mensonges quand quelqu'un dit
la vérité il a tendance à rajouter plein
de détails inutiles si c'était vraiment
un aéroport alors a eu tendance à dire
bah c'était à l'aéroport d'orly où elle
a remporté celle de gaulle ou à
l'aéroport au mexique même d'autres
détails inutiles
j'étais avec mes parents à l'aéroport
d'orly où j'allais attendre un ami à
l'aéroport charles de gaulle là quand
j'ai posé la question il a juste dit
dans un aéroport
c'est un manque de matières inutile et
c'est plus favorable aux mensonges en
temps normal donc pour moi ça me tôt je
suis déjà restée quatre heures bloqué
sur un [ __ ] de télésiège ok je vous
laisse répondre parce que là c'est la
dernière chance et après après cette
réponse je me dirai combien vous en
aviez de bon ou pas si c'était facile
pour vous difficile au contraire une
limite dit moi aussi si vous voulez que
je refasse une vidéo sur comment on
détecte le mensonge quelque chose de
tête à un peu plus actualisés
aujourd'hui en fait c'est vous qui me
dire et puis ça dépendra aussi du nombre
de vues de like de cette vidéo pour voir
si ce sujet là du mensonge qui vous
intéressent au point de refaire quelque
chose elle veut la station je te la
donne tu veux la piste je te la donne à
il veut me convaincre que c'est vraiment
que cette fois aux habitants et bien
voilà ainsi s'achève cette petite anna
glisse de la lnah be c'est ça que tu es
rigolo merci encore aux gars de radio
stream d'allouer les braques c'était
vraiment très très cool cette émission
avec eux n'hésitez pas à liker cette
vidéo dites moi un peu dans les
commentaires répondait aux questions que
vous est posée comme ça je prendrai un
peu la température sur cette thématique
à du mensonge
n'oubliez pas je m'appelle toujours
fabien olicard c'est un mytho ça va
changer vous pouvez vous abonner en
cliquant là active la cloche c'est très
important ici je vous mets aussi de quoi
vous abonner vers ma chaîne secondaire
on publie pas mal de choses en ce moment
allez faire un tour
visite et vous ferez votre avis ensuite
et là je vous mets deux autres analyses
en bas ici c'est eu la dernière année
liszt que j'avais fait quand j'ai
dépassé dans tpm p et là c'est une
analyse politique une ancienne sur
mesure françois hollande qui m'a fait
rire et dont on a reparlé ya pas
longtemps que vous voulez vous vous la
partagez
prenez soin de vous à très très très
très bientôt tutti cha cha cha cha cha
haut